امام ثلاثه الاف مستمع
توفي وهو يغني على مسرح المفتاح في مدينه
ابها بالسعوديه فارق صاحب الحنجره الذهبيه
الحياه في لحظه من المستحيل ان تسقط من
ذاكره محبيه وعشاقه طلال بن عبد الشيخ بن
احمد بن جعفر الجابري احب العزف والغناء
منذ طفولته وكان يغني في الحفلات المدرسيه
وكان والده عاشقا للعزف على الاتي
السمسميه والمدروف التي تشبه المال جاءت
الاقدار ان يتعرف على عبد الرحمن خندنه
واجتمع الاثنان على حب الموسيقى والغناء
حيث كان عبد الرحمن عاشقا للعزف على اله
العود ومنه تعلم طلال مداح العزف على اله
العود وتاثر بافكاره الموسيقيه وبعد مسلسل
طويل من المخاوف والتردد قرر الطلح اول
اغنيه وهي وردك يا زارع الورد ونجحت
الاغنيه داخل السعوديه قدم طلال مداح عبر
مسيرته الفنيه 85 البوما وكان يجيد الغناء
بثمان لهجات عربيه كما اهلته موهبته
الرائعه للتعاون مع عدد كبير من الملحنين
والشعراء في العالم العربي
ومنحه النقاد العديد من الالقاب مثل صوت
الارض صاحب الحنجره ذهبيه وفارس الاغنيه
السعوديه